it's film theory but everytime matpat
makes a cringy joke it gets faster just
like the b-movie memes which are 2017 s
most unbelievable trend but for me no
meme is too strange no internet trend to
dumb it comes exploring the dankest of
memes he might say we are number one
where a lot of math more there's a
little dab'll do ya
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where let's face it it's early in the
year and all the most theorize about new
movies aren't coming out for a couple of
months and sure well I'm just as excited
for fifty shades darker as the next guy
the most exciting things to be talking
about these days are internet trends but
not just any internet trends internet
trends about movies internet trends
about really bad movies where Jerry
Seinfeld is a bee trying to get it on
with a human yes my friends today is an
a-plus theory about the bee movie or
rather a theory on the ultimate meme
that took YouTube by storm over the last
couple months now I know you've seen it
because of the weird ways YouTube forces
you to watch stuff like this the entire
movie without the bees or when they say
be the video speeds up but then it
started to go off the rails as the meta
nosov this started to spiral in on
itself and more memes got looped in kind
of like a sharknado it just became a
parody of itself suddenly we started to
see things like and mind you this is an
actual video on YouTube that was
actually edited together by someone the
B movie trailer but every time they say
B it's we are number one but every time
it says one it's the legend twenty-seven
commercial but for every third the
legend twenty-seven commercial its base
is boosted beyond comprehension but the
second to last one in every we are
number one is replaced by brand Daniel
reading the entire B movie scripts also
the fourth we are number one is the dank
edition and you would think you would
think that this is all just for the
lawls but no this is an actual eight
hour forty seven minute movie where the
channel doctor scrubbing Tonetta
together exactly that based on those
rules B movie we are number one the
legend 27 all in one we've got a bingo
the only thing it's missing is bottle
flipping a DAB in harambe so of course
leave it to the good readers of dank
memes and reddit to take this already
absurd trend and blow it absolutely out
of proportion in an effort to take this
to the absolute max they created the
ultimate b-movie mod and I quote one the
entire Ice Age pentalogy but every
syllable is replaced with the entire Toy
Story trilogy but to every second that
the color green is in frame it's
replaced with every video ever uploaded
onto YouTube but three for every 10
seconds every episode of The Simpsons
plays but for every word with a vowel is
replaced with the B movie but five every
time a B is shown it's replaced with
every episode of Spongebob play
backwards stupid of course it is funny
well I thought so but what really got me
was that in the picture they have this
huge number for the runtime in there for
comedic effect and after I gave this
post one enormous ly sarcastic I roll it
got me thinking how long would this
video actually be it seems like an
impossible question I mean look at some
of the things you have to solve for but
impossible is my middle name
Matthew Robert danger impossible Patrick
and sure there are some answers online
in these reddit threads but um I did the
math and they are completely wrong so
just like a Lannister always pays his
debts so too does the theorists always
show his work and today is dedicated to
determining the length of the longest me
meais video ever to deceive to sharpen
those number-two pencils for some of the
dankest math you've ever seen so right
now you might be reacting like this guy
but here's the good news although this
sounds really complicated the math we
can use to solve it all isn't hard it's
just a bunch of multiplication since
we're just replacing something from one
show or movie with something else if we
can calculate the number of times each
replacement action happens we can use
good ol multiplication to go from the
inside out parentheses within
parentheses within parentheses
parentheses for when math gets meta so
slugs we keep track of our units we
should be fine the bad news though is
that we're gonna be getting into the
territory of really scarily
numbers but hey you can put a lot of big
numbers into the ti-83 silver edition of
course so we should be fine
growing up we didn't have enough money
to buy the silver edition calculator it
was always really jealous of everyone
who hadn't talked about your hashtag
first world problems table real talk
that one came preloaded with games which
was pretty sweet now starting at the end
of the prompt and working our way
backwards makes the most sense because
it has the simplest parameters so to
begin we turn to the overlord of meme
dumb himself Spongebob Squarepants
the original meme stipulates that the
episodes of Spongebob be played
backwards but as long as we're playing
them at a standard speed it's not gonna
change how long they are so it's an easy
number to find at the time of this
recording we've been asking about the
resident of a pineapple
two hundred five times in all take out
all the commercial breaks in each
episode is gonna clock in at about
twenty two minutes or one thousand three
hundred twenty seconds the total time
for the whole series then figures out to
be two hundred seventy thousand six
hundred seconds meaning that if you can
give up sleep work school in the toilet
you can actually catch up with the
entirety of SpongeBob's misadventures in
a little over three days straight
spoiler alert you still won't know the
Krabby Patty secret formula it might
just get a chuckle out of the fact that
mr. Krabs lives in a place called Bikini
Bottom get it Krabs bikini bottom edgy
[Music]
sure only three days might sound like
we're getting off to a slow start but
remember that's three solid days of
Spongebob for every single instance of
the other rules so are you ready for
more math I figured you might be let's
continue the next layer outward is the B
movie rule we play those Spongebob
Squarepants episodes every time we see a
B in the B movie now in a shocking
development there are actually a lot of
B's in the B movie but here's where we
have to start interpreting the meme a
little bit what does it mean by every
time we see a B one run through of
Sponge Bob for every B in every frame
that seems a bit like overkill
instead I opted for a slightly more
conservative approach every second a
beat was in the frame throughout the
movie the runtime of B movie if you cut
out all the credits and the dreamwork
stuff at the beginning is 82 minutes and
four seconds B movie without the B's on
the other hand is a poultry 12 minutes
and 28 seconds meaning that there are 69
minutes and 36 seconds worth of pervy
B's looking to have an inner species
romance and thank you so much again I
see what you did there completely by
coincidence B movie I mean what's the
deal with B's trying to get it on with
human women who thought that that would
be a good idea at the box-office am i
right
Jerry Seinfeld the guy who called
YouTube the garbage can of contents
thanks to us that anyone even cares
about that stupid movie of yours
go have more coffee with comedians in
cars anyway that puts us at 7,000 136
seconds or 7,000 136 times that we're
gonna have to play all those spongebob
episodes all the way through actually at
7,000 136 runs of every spongebob
episode for every one of our next rule
every single episode of The Simpsons but
every word spoken that contains a vowel
being replaced with the B movie which is
yadda yadda yadda that's another
Seinfeld thing you get the point by now
The Simpsons is currently in the midst
of its 28th season and has aired 609
different episodes so how many Crom
Yulin twords and big in each episode of
The Simpsons
well we studied the transcripts of a few
different Simpsons
including ones with wordless montages
like last exit to Springfield as well as
those with a lot of dialogue like homey
the clown the average number of words
per Simpsons script was about 2145 and
because most words have a vowel in there
somewhere we just assumed that it was a
hundred percent so two thousand one
hundred forty five times six hundred and
nine episodes means 1.3 million words
over the course of those six hundred
nine episodes in other words that's one
point three million times we'd have to
repeat all the previous conditions and
now we get to the big one the runtime of
all the videos ever uploaded to YouTube
you'd think as someone who's lived and
breathed YouTube for years now that I'd
have the inside track on this one but uh
no this one I actually have to calculate
out YouTube keeps a lot of stats close
to its chest but using previously talked
about statistics can get us a pretty
darn good estimate projections from late
2015 claimed that YouTube had 500 hours
of video uploaded every minute which
would likely be even higher now with
YouTube's continued growth so if you
take previous announcements from YouTube
on its yearly upload rates with my
personal favorite being 2012's YouTube
April Fool's video which stated in an
hour of video is uploaded to YouTube
every second Wow
an hour a second oh it's nearly ten
times that five years later that is
insane and most of those minutes are
b-movie memes or thousand-degree knife
videos what's it gonna cut through this
time oh I bet it cuts through the shoe
yeah it cut through the shoe oh I bet it
cuts through the ice Wow
haha nice melted ice no duh speaking of
thousand degree knife videos it's like
the only trend that's not being covered
in this video
get with it thousand degree knife videos
become me mesh anyway by using this
graph and similar ones that lists off
average bulk time of video uploaded to
YouTube every hour broken down by the
year you get over 630 million hours of
video that have ever been uploaded to
YouTube and since we're measuring it in
seconds well yeah you should probably
just stop thinking about the raw numbers
at this point and instead think about
keyboard Cats one of the greatest
talents to ever appear on this site
across those six hundred thirty million
plus
next step to Toy Story and beyond the
three Toy Story movies have a total run
time of 4 hours 36 minutes and 40 seems
that kick your right in the fields so
that's a total run time of 16,000 561
seconds now the rule here is that for
every one of those seconds in which the
color green is visible in the frame this
super-sized meme repeats all the
previously mentioned steps and it's here
that I have to make a bit of a
confession
forgive me internet for I have sinned I
didn't study all three hundred ninety
seven thousand four hundred sixty-four
frames of all three Toy Story movies
because honestly that's what it would
take with 24 frames per second and
16,000 561 seconds of movie it's nearly
400,000 frames to explore it just can't
be done but what I did do is take
selected clips from each of the three
movies slow them down and determine what
percentage of time Green was visible it
averaged out to be a staggering eighty
four point six percent of the time and
it makes a lot of sense when you think
about it buzz has green on him Rex is
green the army men are green the aliens
are green the furniture is green all the
outdoor scenes with trees and grass or
green Sid's eyes are green there is a
lot of green in these movies especially
for Pixar Emma right but seriously
that's why they're creating a fourth Toy
Story movie right shameless cash-grab I
like money anywho I digress sixteen
thousand five hundred sixty-one seconds
times eighty four point six percent of
seconds with green in them rounds out to
fourteen thousand and eleven seconds in
which the color green is in frame
throughout the Toy Story trilogy whoa we
are almost there guys and last but
certainly not least we have the Ice Age
movies everything we've calculated so
far is repeated for every single
syllable in all five wait five there
have been five Ice Age movies man I
missed a couple of those
alright so every syllable and each Ice
Age movie forces us to repeat everything
we've calculated so far when I first
started working on this episode I
thought for sure that this one would be
the hardest one to calculate but I was
surprisingly able to get a pretty exact
calculation by taking the transcripts
spoken dialogue only for each of the
five movies cutting it into manageable
pieces and then running it through an
automated syllable counter granted the
syllable counter couldn't read
a few words like scrat's but it did give
us the otherwise reasonable count of
thirty four thousand eighty five
syllables across the five movies oh and
with that it's time to recap we have the
two hundred seventy thousand six hundred
seconds of Spongebob footage repeated
seven thousand one hundred thirty six
times for every second of visible B's
and B movie which is shown once for
every one of the 1 million three hundred
six thousand one hundred five words
spoken with a vowel in the Simpsons
Canon which is then repeated every ten
seconds of the 630 million seven hundred
twenty thousand hours of video that have
ever been uploaded to YouTube which
rolls fourteen thousand and eleven times
due to the green seconds in Toy Story
one two and three which all plays once
for every single one of the thirty four
thousand eighty five syllables in the
Ice Age pentalogy make sure that you've
converted it all the seconds multiplied
it all the way through then convert it
to years and we get the drumroll worthy
number of I said the drumroll worthy
number of seriously where's the drumroll
[Music]
the dramatic slide whistle worthy number
of eight octillion six hundred
seventy-two septillion 127 sextillion
482 quintillion years just about eight
and a half octillion years if you round
down now if you're like me you hear a
number like that and you're like what
the heck does that mean
and yeah when you're talking about
numbers this huge it's really hard to
wrap your head around so let's look at
this giant number from a couple
different angles first it's worth noting
that earth as a planet has been around a
little bit more than four-and-a-half
billion years and the whole universe
about 13.7 billion years now billion and
octillion might both sound like
impossibly large numbers but trust me
octillion are way bigger if you started
playing this video from the moment the
Big Bang occurred
straight through to today it would be
less than 1% of the way through the
YouTube videos which would mean that
you're on the first second of Toy Story
and the first spoken syllable of Ice Age
remember that there are 34,000 syllables
of ice age to get through and it took us
from the Big Bang to now and we're still
only on the first one scientists
estimate that the Sun will explode in
the next four to five billion years
taking earth with it
so by the time the planet Earth ceases
to exist this video would still be going
on this is also around the time that the
universe is supposed to die via heat
death so time and space will come to an
end but bad movie memes will outlive us
all so how do you illustrate a length of
time that's truly longer than the
lifespan of the universe what is the
best way to convey to you how long this
video is let me put it this way let's
say that we set up a race where one
person sets out to watch this video from
start to finish and another person puts
all of Earth's water into one giant
eyedropper and then tries to refill all
those bodies of water one drop or one
milliliter at a time the person with the
giant eyedropper would still win if they
only put in one drop one milliliter of
water every 5,000 years ever tried to
fill an ocean with an eyedropper one
drop every 5,000 years it is gonna take
a while don't even get me started on how
long that damn video would take to
buffer but hey that's just a theory a
film theory
and cut
[Music]
you